Yeah.
So,
um,
good afternoon everyone.
Thank you so much for coming out.
We have an incredible author and speaker this afternoon.
Um,
so without further ado,
I'll introduce the dean.
[inaudible] Dean is the author of the book embracing survival.
She was appointed eight youth peace ambassador in 2013 for the Egis Trust,
an organization dedicated to the prevention of genocide and mass atrocities
worldwide.
Subsequently,
in 2015,
she became global mentor for Peace at serve two unite and organization that
cultivates piece through creative service learning and global engagement.
Did Dean is committed to establishing a dialogue between people for
understanding their shared histories and cultural differences through her
writing and public lectures.
Her goal is to pierce the wall of silence that still pervades much of our
society.
Please join me in welcoming Dean woman,
Yana
okay.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
So the dean welcome.
Um,
why don't we start by taking us back to Rwanda in 1994 and providing the context
and setting for this powerful and inspiring story.
Um,
uh,
well,
back in 1994,
I was,
uh,
I was four years old,
so some baby and I'd lived with my grandparents.
Um,
I remember the first day of the genocide on a pro seventh.
It was actually because the genocide started April 6th,
the night of [inaudible].
So I,
I lived in eastern province of Rwanda and the genocide had already started in
the city,
in the capital city of Rwanda and displayed throughout the country that in the
morning in eastern province.
Then that's where,
that's when the genocide began,
where it was and my grandparent's house.
And as a,
as a child,
I remember five in the morning,
my,
uh,
my aunt Agnes,
she woke up,
she woke us all up.
And uh,
as she,
as,
as I walked in the living room,
all,
all my cousins were sitting in the,
on the flow and my aunt,
um,
with feeling as though we're going to church see was my favorite activity.
Um,
I mean my childhood to get out of the house and go to church.
So it was really exciting and I am the,
and I screamed out loud to her that I wanted to dress my beautiful too,
to where my beautiful dress,
uh,
the group migrant that gave me the Christmas before that year.
And,
uh,
she,
she shouldn't be too to not be loud.
If I need anything I should,
we spur from then on.
So it was a little bit scared,
but still wanting my dress and a,
and a,
my little dress was a white little dress with the three butterflies and I loved
it so much.
So it was my opportunity to wear it.
And she was,
she ran in the room and he brought it,
brought it back and just me out and give me a jar of milk because she was given,
we were more than almost 12 children in the house because before the genocide,
um,
the Hutu government used to kill or put in jail.
The tutes is who are young and seem to find back.
So in the preparation of the genocide so they can succeed.
That was one of the things they did,
um,
apart from,
aside from buying machetes.
And the uniforms and all of that was also,
yeah,
those part of it.
So my parents fled Rwanda before the genocides.
That's why I was in my grandparent's house.
But when,
uh,
when we're about to leave,
she give everyone if we're child a little something to eat or drink because she
didn't know where that journey will end.
And so it's,
so she gave me the milk.
Um,
but when we left the house,
the streets was,
was full of people.
People are being fleeing all night from Kigali and do,
hadn't been walking.
It's,
it's a 30 minute drive from Kigali to eastern province where it,
where it was.
But people had been working so they had a lot of things with them.
We're caring,
um,
mattresses and food and children.
It was just a lot,
a lot of people.
And um,
we joined them but I'm always,
um,
I didn't write in the book but I always had this feeling of a little shame
because it was somehow excited for me.
It was really exciting that moment and I always felt it.
And it never even told anyone cause like,
cause after the genocide or cause the how and the when I was growing up was how
did I feel that excitement's but as a child,
I don't know.
So as we were walking towards a catheter in,
in the,
in the city of,
in the small city of the view,
that village,
um,
there was a lot of,
we solos and songs,
uh,
the Hutus were singing songs of hate in the name of God.
And a,
and the,
we start started blowing around if we're in the heel is,
and,
and I don't know what happened that moment because I lost everyone.
Yes.
So you probably remember in the book and,
uh,
and I found myself in a home of puppet traders.
So they were,
my grandparents is,
uh,
neighbors.
I played with their children.
And,
uh,
I didn't really quite remember most of everything because we just stayed in me.
But I didn't,
we didn't know because after the genocide,
when we're United with my parents and my mom had to bring me back there.
So that I will not,
um,
end up like my father because my father had trauma and all of that and she
figured that will have the same thing as she wanted to know what happened to me
cause it was in this hot,
this home of perpetrators and nobody,
the new me and my family wasn't there.
So it was the only one,
uh,
lined up with so many other Tutsis and it was the little one there.
And they started killing everyone.
And as they got to me,
I,
um,
I asked for milk if I can drink my milk and,
and um,
I don't know where I got the thirst to ask for milk,
but the milk saved me.
It did because when I asked for milk was almost a confirmation to the puppy
traders that I am a Tutsi child and my parents are in the RPF.
They knew me,
they knew who I was.
So the resistance,
the resistance,
where in Uganda,
that's both my parents were there.
And of course those puppets,
where's is my neighbors?
So they knew who I was.
They knew my parents,
they knew the whole or ground.
But asking for milk,
it was,
um,
I will say this for maybe,
I don't know if I'm right,
but in Rwanda,
before I came here,
they used to say a big was there for Jewish people.
They were,
there it goes.
So it was almost,
you were in the front of Nazis and you are a child and you're asking for a
Bagel.
So it's a confirmation that you are a Jew.
So,
um,
when I asked for me,
like culturally,
Tutsis owned cows,
so the know culture,
children of tutors drink milk in the morning and for dinner,
for lunch,
everything.
So asking them for milk,
they paused and mimic me.
And because,
um,
and started saying,
Oh,
you want to be a child of Tutsi,
if you did not ask for milk,
you won't be a cockroach or snack because they didn't really see us as humans.
So we're a snake or a cockroach on it.
In that moment when they were mimicking me and really aloud,
uh,
someone hurt them inside the house.
And it was,
that was that,
it was an ugly men who walked out and he saw me in the lion.
Um,
most,
most everyone was already killed.
Um,
and,
um,
we're very breathing and he,
and he asked them why one day working.
So the way the propaganda's were on the,
the told the young Hutus CIFO killer is that it's work going out there and to
kill Tutsis,
it's a job.
It's a work.
You have to wake up and go work.
So when he walked outside Rita,
he was frustrated that they're not working,
they're just talking.
And he was Hutu as well.
She was who to me with the Grandpas,
those kids.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and when he saw me in the line,
I don't know why he got PD,
but he,
uh,
he told them that they should be ashamed of killing an innocent child if w when
their wives are caring,
do children are different from me.
So he rushed in and,
and Steve to me,
um,
and,
uh,
he put me in between his pair of his legs and then they finished everyone there
and he throw me under the bed.
So under a wooden bed in the house.
Um,
so that was the first day of the genocide.
And of course there were 90,
90 more days to go.
Yes.
Um,
and I,
I was a child,
so I didn't remember most of those days,
but my mom,
when my mom took me back there,
I had to,
I was almost seven or eight cause I had nightmares when I was growing up and I
wouldn't dream of dead people dying or people killing each other and that they
will be,
I would think in my dreams.
They are my family,
the people that I know.
So I couldn't really Shamil ally's my dreams and the reality like will take me a
time to go back to sleep when my mom would bring me every one of my brothers and
oh,
babysitters,
everyone.
So she will confirm to me that,
uh,
it was just a dream,
but when she helped me and take me back there,
um,
they started going away because they knew what really happened to me because I
could then pieces of,
uh,
of,
of that.
Yes.
So there were,
um,
I believe the stat is,
yeah,
an estimated 1 million Rwandans were killed during the genocide.
20% of the population,
70% of the Tutsi population was killed.
Give us your sense of some of the,
the drivers of that level of hatred and what underpinned that type of activity
that,
that drove that level of,
of hatred and genocide in,
in the country.
You mentioned colonialism,
the power of colonialism in there.
Okay.
Was
going,
I'll let you go again.
Sure.
I know because,
uh,
the more I grow older and learn more about like how,
cause I couldn't understand how it didn't might people kill each other.
We weren't,
we,
we spoke the same language.
We're all black when this tiny little country and how in the world,
how did we end up killing each other at dinner?
We understanding of course I would just learn how my father,
his entire family was wiped out and learning any,
you wouldn't learn anything from my dad except the pain that he's feeling
because he was already traumatized it.
Same with my mom.
So it was really a confusion.
And growing up in,
in Rwanda having that history,
I couldn't quite a really understand the reason behind it.
So I think when I was 18,
I got the chance to go to the ruin a genocide museum and learn the history and
background of the genocide for the first time.
And that's the first time that I was able to have compassion even towards
children,
out of perpetrators because then I started feeling them how they feel if they
know that their families has done such a thing.
That's like a,
it's just a shame that you carry on and do we end?
They didn't even do anything.
So I ha I learned so much about what [inaudible] calls the genocide,
but we read it to really understand those three months of the genocide,
you have to revisit the cornea or the Colonia error.
Sure.
Because before the,
the colonial era,
um,
the Rwandans did not have tribes or ethnics or classes,
you know,
it was classes actually.
So,
uh,
we was,
the Tutsis were the elite class and the Hutus with the,
the,
the middle class in the twin or the word poor.
And,
and the hunters mainly.
So they lived together.
They shared everything.
And you,
if you own more than 10 cows,
you will join the Tutsi class because we did not have money.
So we'll count the richness.
I don't know how to say it in English,
but,
well a few wealth,
it depends on how many colors that you have.
So,
uh,
when the colonias came,
which I always feel like we're really,
uh,
it was an in 19,
early 1930 days.
And that for me,
I feel like we can never give what we don't have.
So when the Germans came in Rwanda back then,
you know what was happening in New York,
it was holocaust that was going on.
And that's the only thing they brought in a Rwanda.
So they started categorizing Rwandans,
studying them,
measuring their noses are dividing them.
And uh,
seeing the Tutsis are told that lighter skin,
they probably are from Ethiopia.
So,
um,
they're not from saint choice Africa and the Hutus are the,
so they wouldn't really measuring everyone to putting them in the classes and
they used to give them ID cards.
Um,
and I don't know how my people,
they accepted that,
but I don't know cause that's,
yeah,
I was way before it was born.
But they learned how different they were.
It took few decades to,
for them to really,
I guess it's easy to teach hate
because they learn in only three decades.
And when they,
when the Germans left and give the country to the Belgians because the Germans
were,
were losing power in Africa,
um,
the Belgiums had Congo and Congo is huge and had them ends and all that.
So they give one or two Belgian so they can rule it together.
But really Rwanda had nothing.
It did not have minerals,
didn't have,
sue was just a little part of Africa.
Small and the beautiful,
they can just have the,
almost a headquarters.
So,
um,
in 19,
in 1959,
the,
the killed the king.
They say,
I'm not 100% sure if the really the Belgians poison the king in de Bruyn de,
but when they did kill the king,
um,
the,
the Hutus to cover.
So when they'll colonias in Aronda they promise they built schools,
hospitals.
Um,
and those,
all those privileges were,
were for the elite class.
So the WHO,
two children wouldn't go to those schools.
So really the constantly began from what we are having more than we are and this
is a lowland,
how dare you have all of this.
So when the Hutus got in power,
they were already angry.
The Tutsis that they are not from there and they're having everything.
So they wanted to kill everyone.
So the civil war really began in 1959.
And the,
the,
the key the child does,
prince fled with a lot of Tutsis and the neighboring countries and um,
the tutors who stay in the country lived in fear.
So the,
everywhere in the country they started learning how the tutors are not humans.
So those propagandas the name calling really begun.
I in 1915 and there was a lot of civil war in [inaudible] 68 to 72.
Um,
so really the,
the 1994 it was,
it was,
uh,
it was the time for the race to race on the planet.
And it was well organized,
well planned because I remember when I was growing up hearing stories that on
how the government will give,
cause he used to train young people who are at 16,
15.
Um,
and then we'll train them how to kill and with the traditional weapons.
and there's the,
there's this one with them.
They used to call.
It's really interesting cause they,
that's the one they wanted to use or to use on me.
And as a child I never get it.
Like even the weapon is cold.
No period for the enemy.
How can my child be an enemy?
Because you really don't even know who you are.
But I'm there.
When they were training the CFO killers,
um,
the,
they give away free small radios and these radios,
you could chart them on the sun.
Now this is a very poor country,
but,
but um,
how hatred can really work.
He will spend everything you have to really succeed in Haiti and in Haiti.
So the,
the,
um,
that's why the genocide succeeded in only three months.
In a million people were killed because neighbors were killing neighbors.
And in one night they were ready for it.
They,
in one night,
those radios,
the only thing that was on radios was go kill the enemy.
Hmm.
Um,
and do you just,
it just happened like that,
but it was already in the hearts of people.
Yeah.
People won't,
they justified it because they couldn't,
they didn't,
they had already learned for a long time that the Tutsis are not human.
Yes.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I think,
I think even in,
uh,
in the world today,
people justify calling each other names and um,
yeah.
And,
and they forget that when you're doing that,
you're actually losing year.
You're human.
Yeah.
She managed it because being a human is being,
having,
loving and being kind and having compassion towards each other,
but mostly the popular trails.
I actually think of themselves as more human as,
yeah.
That's the other side.
So let's,
let's talk about your story more directly because the memoir really focuses so
much on the family and you're familiar relationships and there are a source of
both power and a comfort.
But also,
um,
there was a lot of difficulty connected with the relationship with your,
with your mom,
especially with your dad.
The separation of them is you mentioned when you were a child.
Um,
but also like the valor of the extended family,
people like on to Agnes who were rescuers in many ways.
So as a child,
how did you process family then?
How,
how did it play a role in your sense of survival and as you reflect now as an
adult woman,
how do those,
uh,
those perspectives on family,
how are they different or similar?
I think it cultivates it coated in something in me that was,
uh,
these life is not just from me.
And I think it's kind of,
it's,
um,
it's kind of like a nice idea.
It's a savior.
Like it can save your soul because then you become stronger than you can eat.
You can think because you're leaving for your siblings,
you're leaving for somebody else.
And,
um,
and I remember at 13 years old I couldn't,
I couldn't understand the life.
I couldn't,
I couldn't understand life.
My,
uh,
I have,
when genocide ended,
I had just made my parents for the first time since birth.
So was always really,
really excited to experience love from a parent for the first time.
But it was not there.
Um,
the hardware were already destroyed.
They had,
my parents
had lost his siblings,
his nieces,
his parents,
and he couldn't see life.
And that's the person I was supposed to learn from,
how to love life and all of that.
My mother was the same.
She never,
she was strong,
very strong.
She never cried.
I never saw her crying for help siblings.
But the other day for the first time,
23 years later,
she cried for her brothers and she,
cause she was in a therapy session and,
and then she called me,
she said,
I think I'm being weaker.
And I said,
why?
She said,
I promised my family that I stayed so that I can take care of their family,
their children,
but now I am.
So she never really took the time to grieve.
And,
um,
and I think that's where,
even for me it was more of like,
even when,
uh,
when I was about to,
this is it,
I don't really want this life.
Why would God create life if meant to suffer?
Um,
I remember when to this lake in the north of Rwanda and,
uh,
I had to really,
really giving up on life.
But when I got there,
we lived with my father then and he was always traumatized.
Then for some reason he's trauma is trauma,
told him that he will be easier if he will be,
um,
then,
but not with a machete.
It's,
they didn't want us to suffer as his family did.
So,
so would really suffered from that and will flee all the time from him.
And,
and this time I said,
this is it.
I'm done.
But when I got there,
for some reason I thought of my brothers and sister and I thought,
Whoa,
how were they going to take the news?
How were they going to leave if,
if I'm the oldest and I'm doing this for,
so I've,
I've cried for them and fell asleep.
Thank God.
And I woke up around 6:00 PM when a gardener was kicking me and kicking me out
of the,
the other beach because the children were not allowed to stay there later than
six.
So those kind of little moments saved my life.
But I think was more because my family had this value of loving the entire
family.
Even when they found out you were long
lost cousin,
you weren't they?
Yes.
And this,
this,
that protection that when my aunt doing that,
my aunt was my age,
Jake,
almost my age to other genocide,
Agnes and she took care of all those children.
She was the only adult in the fence.
She never had children.
And she had my brother through all those three months in her back.
Um,
so,
and even when she tried to leave him,
she did not because,
you know,
fleeing,
running,
and now I cannot imagine myself doing what she did.
Um,
when I think of it as like,
would I really be able to take care of all these children if anything happens?
But,
um,
I think when you extend yourself to be something bigger than yourself,
he actually helps you.
It helps you not,
yeah.
More than you can imagine.
Yeah.
So talk,
talk to us about the,
the escape to Uganda
or did you get out ultimately,
um,
during the genocide?
During the genocide?
Well,
um,
so in eastern province it's the one main road that goes all the way to Uganda.
Um,
and when we're fleeing,
um,
we were heading to Uganda,
we,
which we did not really make it there,
but I remember a few things went because on the way there,
my dad who was,
uh,
was big in the military in the,
in the RPF,
when he really came back,
he was looking for us and he looked for us first.
Uh,
and he couldn't find us.
We found that we made in the streets cause he's so my aunt and he recognized her
and then he came,
he came to us,
but I didn't know him.
My baby brother did not and he wanted to take us and my,
um,
my brother crying cause he didn't know who this guy was.
And my aunt looked at me,
she had her way of looking and you'll know what she's talking about.
She's a really strong woman.
And she looked at me and she said that,
then you go,
this is your dad and we'll meet you.
So cause I was,
she couldn't really carry all of us.
So I put him on a motorcycle.
He wasn't a motorcycle then and we actually went back.
So my aunt is,
my aunt was going to Uganda because my dad was on a mission.
He brought me back,
uh,
in,
in Rwanda.
Which,
um,
those,
those are,
those are memories that didn't leave me because when we were going back,
if there were dead bodies everywhere and,
and,
and uh,
in the streets.
And I remember it was fun meeting on him.
Um,
cause I was,
I was holding him from the back and I,
I would try to closing my eyes,
but I was smelling because had been there.
Um,
yeah.
So she,
few days later he left me in a comp soldiers come cause he was,
um,
he was,
he went on a mission.
I left,
made some soldiers and it was,
it didn't go well.
So you have to take me back to my eyes because I couldn't eat and drink or do
anything.
And they decided to find my aunt because my aunt told before,
culturally,
because the tension that was in Rwanda,
they already knew that they did not like each other tribes.
So even when you were a child,
they will tell you never eat in a stranger's home.
That's right.
Or never take anything from a stranger.
So I couldn't open my mouth for anything from anybody that I don't know,
except it wasn't my aunt or someone I know.
So when my dad took me,
I didn't know him and I didn't know anybody,
so I did not have any even water.
So he decided to take me find my aunt and we went to the center,
a small center and,
but things were really getting bad because then it was not just my shit.
Is the government though the military,
the Hutu government,
the,
the x far you just to call them.
Yeah.
The x far had started fighting with,
uh,
with,
without a PFS was not now.
It wasn't just not running from somebody was running from bullets,
from grenades.
And it was,
it was then,
it was a war.
Yeah.
So this place where my aunts,
where we're hiding where the are a Pfo was rescue,
I don't,
the rest of fuels tutors never hide left and put them in small centers and
gotten them.
Then the who took government would throw grenades on those places.
So when it got there,
that's what I,
I've,
I guess I fell asleep when my dad was taking me there and I woke up in with my
aunt and,
uh,
was everything was flying.
And um,
so,
um,
yeah.
So it was those kind of,
those kind of moments.
Yeah.
So the title of your book is,
is embracing survival and if you,
if you had to try and locate what were those things that allowed you to survive
and to kind of emerge to where you are today sitting on this stage,
where,
where do you locate those,
those critical things that allowed you to hold on and to survive during that
time?
Hmm.
Well,
I think,
you know,
it's,
um,
the surviving the genocide.
It's one thing then surviving after surviving,
it's another thing.
Yeah.
Cause um,
cause it's really hard because you life just changes completely.
And of course you don't know any other life and,
and that's the only thing that is around you.
So it's really one way you survive or then,
or you die.
Um,
most of the survivors did not,
they're all,
most of them I reckon my dad or the or the already passed away after the
genocide or they became alcoholic or drags or twice you to just anything that
will just make them not think.
So it was really those,
those traces that we had.
And um,
and for me,
I guess I was,
I d I guess my dad was more of like a learning for me.
So I always cause even when,
when I was having those nightmares as a kid,
my mom would be like,
I cannot take it.
If you end up like your dad.
And she was really strict streets,
she wouldn't,
if I remember when it was,
my biggest dream was to go to boarding school to turn 12 and go to a boarding
school.
And the Sh.
I remember when I was going to school,
she told me like,
you know,
when you're sending your kid to school or girl,
you would tell her some things like to take care of yourself.
What are some sweet things?
No,
she was,
don't dare get traumatized.
So I really carry,
I did carry that with me and I knew that if,
if I'm broken inside,
that's what I'm going to be giving and I will try so hard to do.
When I loved,
I loved singing,
I loved writing.
So I would rate my emotions down and I'm seeing,
oh,
become a church girl or,
so I do all those little things,
but I didn't know that was my survival techniques until then.
I was here three and a half years ago and I remember calling my survivor friend
after two weeks and they told her,
you know,
I didn't know that one can sleep all night,
all night long without anything,
just flipping.
Yes.
So really for me,
when I was growing up,
sleeping was luxury.
Like knowing that you're going to sleep in,
just sleep all night.
And,
um,
and I,
and I guess I ended up learning how to embrace that life.
Yeah.
And just the way it was in love with the way it was and just knowing that
there's someone out there who was leaving a worst life.
Donna,
how was that saves me in going to the museum,
seeing this children who are my age.
Um,
what do you not survive?
It made me for the first time,
I appreciate it.
The person who walked out and choose to save me,
but,
well,
I'd never met him.
I wish he goes,
when we went back,
he had already passed away women to see his wife,
but I always feel this,
um,
this gratitude towards his,
so,
you know,
the,
and those people are around there.
We have a lot of good people like that,
but he did save me.
And for some reason I just seem like,
why am I even alive?
So there's a reason and,
uh,
and it's not just for me,
it's for other children out there who are going through the same thing.
To know that there is hope.
Tomorrow's going to be okay.
Which is where you're devoting your life to now.
Yeah.
So we're gonna open it up for questions if,
if folks want to throw up at the mix.
Um,
so bring us up to today.
What,
what's the status of Rwanda today?
Um,
how were you,
how were you connected to the country?
How have things changed?
What's your perspective there?
I think Rhonda today is,
is okay.
I wouldn't say that he's perfect because it's only been 23 years and it takes a
long time to peace then teaching.
He taught some reason hate this really loud.
And when love is like quiet and people don't like to one pill,
it's vulnerable.
Yes.
So we don't get to learn it as much as when hate goes over there,
but we're trying to learn to have reconciliation,
forgiveness,
having survivors learn how to forgive because it's really more for the survivor,
uh,
to be able to leave after,
after the journals,
the survival.
Um,
and I,
I love The v after genocide,
they actually learned that there were no reason to have tribes.
So Tho those stores some people's hearts and minds.
But in our ID cards there's no tribes.
You're just a London,
which was a big Stape and I hope maybe we'll take a generations and generations.
I,
but I,
I hope that one day,
um,
younger children's,
we'll look at each other and just see them,
see each other as humans,
not thinking twice about,
cause that's how he grew up and grew up looking at my Lou,
my classmates.
And the first thing I'll want to know is where they're coming from,
what their tribe and my enemies and then they are not,
they are just children like me.
Yes.
So the country is trying to move forward and heal,
but it will take very and very long time.
Yeah.
Any questions so far?
Okay.
Um,
so just staying on the,
on the topic of contemporary situation in Africa specifically,
I share with you an article by Nicholas Kristof of the New York Times.
And the title of this article was conflict is more profitable than piece.
And the,
the article was about the Cert,
the current situation in the Central African Republic and the genocide.
That's been happening there for about 14 years now.
Um,
and the premise of the article was that for us to actually eradicate poverty and
all of the difficulties in developing countries,
we have to first deal with conflict and apparently 80% of UN humanitarian
budgets these days goes to dealing with conflict as opposed to getting people
food and those sorts of things.
So what,
what do you think is behind that kind of intractable issue of conflict in places
like the central,
the Central African Republic,
South Sudan,
Yamen what,
what is the,
what is the answer there in terms of dealing with that kind of a conflict that
just continues to perpetuate itself?
I think for me,
I think,
um,
you when or because they can look,
look,
look over the whole entire world.
For me,
I think it's really,
cause when there's conflict it takes a lot of work to fix it,
but there's ways that you can see the conflict is coming and to prevent it
before it happens to really less work.
Then you donate grow coach,
how would you call it?
Raw Red Cross,
right.
There is a lot of,
um,
a lot of,
a lot of work when there's conflicts,
people that it's not really profitable.
Well,
I don't know.
His point was that it's profitable for the perpetrator,
the puppy treader but they kind of,
uh,
for me,
I think the puppy traders,
they think they're profiting,
but they're not because most of the time for me,
I think the puppet or is doing the general side,
where are they now?
They don't have a life.
They're the,
they're in prison or they're fleeing all of her.
But can you imagine if you've taken millions of lives,
you're not really profiting maybe in that moment,
but he would,
he just,
I,
they just need to be informed.
And most of the time,
um,
we need to really educate people the importance of profiting from peace because
it's more profitable.
You have more joy,
you are happy,
and when you're happy,
everything makes sense.
Yeah.
So I,
I think if they can be able to prevent it before it happens,
if they can be able to share this world,
because I guess,
I dunno why,
but one,
um,
one person say that we share the same sky,
we share the same sun because we don't have control over them.
So we can't really fight for it.
But we'd learned,
um,
people should think it.
Think about it the fan wise because really what is home,
it's where my hard is because you just find,
you find yourself there.
You never ask where to be born,
unifies the color of your skin or ask family rules.
I really want to be born in a very,
very wealthy family.
No,
that's never going to happen.
You just find yourself there.
So why in the world who would you blame somebody to be born the way they are?
It's just more of like educating our children for educating,
uh,
we in the,
in the curriculums,
they should really include peacebuilding.
They should,
they should teach children to love each other and just be as if you're teaching
a history,
but have,
have the importance of peace.
How it is,
how I fixed individuals and,
and uh,
knowing,
giving the children that,
just giving them that,
I think it's having a PC as well.
If it's life and if we don't have peace,
we don't have life.
Yes.
So they're the UN and they should learn.
I don't try to create a system where if a child is born,
they don't even think twice then,
oh,
I am this color or I'm this or that's that.
Just see ourselves as humans and the won't,
we won't have to deal with people killing each other or the entitlements.
This is my land,
this is mine.
And just knowing that we can,
I think the world is not that poor.
No,
we make it,
pour it or we have more than a week we should and,
and then there are people will not have anything.
So if we can be able to have compassion and give more and prevent this kind of
killings in Rwanda,
we hired someone seeing it before it happened.
I guess millions of people have.
Hundreds of people would have been saved.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes sir.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you.
Your story is amazing and you are truly inspirational.
Um,
can you tell us if you're involved with any organizations or efforts here?
Uh,
as you said,
you know,
hate somehow screams and love is more vulnerable.
Uh,
some curious about efforts that you're involved with to help teach children or
just people in general about compassion and love and acceptance and tolerance
and all of that good stuff.
I am,
um,
I am involved with this one.
Um,
a nonprofit,
it's called tea at night and it was founded by a farmer.
White supremacy is,
he's my friend.
I met him the first time,
my find,
my first talk when I got here.
It was three months after I got here,
my English,
some horrible,
but he had,
he had patience to listen to me and uh,
and they learned so much about his work and,
and it was a curious because when I came here,
before I came here,
I learned a lot about,
about the,
about the civil right movements and all of these things,
the history of America.
And he was like,
oh my God.
Like if this is a lot,
but I know what's a lot of movies.
Cause when I met him with all these tattoos and he has a really very heavy voice
because he was a rock and roll when he was young.
So he's voices are greeted and I was strong.
Um,
he told me about his work and I asked him,
how,
how did you change?
And he said,
you know,
I,
I changed because I had a daughter and it was very young and it was a single
died in one day where I,
the other store in the car and my daughter,
so at what men walking?
And she said,
Oh dad,
look at that Nigga at four years old.
So for the first time,
that's when that word sounded wrong in his ears.
And he,
he told her to never say it.
And he tried because he had learned so much the compassion when he was,
it was at a thing in his 20s.
Um,
he had received a lot of kindness from a Jewish person,
from a black person that helped him because it was,
oh,
it was too drunk or just in a misery.
Because mostly when you have the hate we are,
you are hurting yourself.
You know,
you're not happy at all.
You just want to blame the entire world because of your misery.
But when he changed,
he became,
he's a wonderful Saul.
He's an amazing person.
Sometimes I tell him,
are you doing this because you're paying back?
And uh,
but he just,
so he has this group that you,
he leaves in Milwaukee and I,
I,
I told,
I speak to the children.
They actually designed,
the children are 14,
13.
They designed this cover out would have done them since a huge poetry they met
when I was finishing my book and they send me a picture and I was like,
oh my,
this is going to be my book cover.
So,
um,
these children,
the serve two unite,
they learn piece and I share with them my story and they ask me questions.
Really beautiful.
Children are very,
very authentic.
They tell you what they think.
So there's those programs and um,
and I work with our last deal.
My friend Aaron is,
is here and his wife,
they're the founder of the,
I'm not a prophet and a helping children,
um,
to learn,
and uh,
to go to call to nicer schools,
children from underserved communities.
Um,
so I end up with age is trust.
That's when I started in my public speaking,
sharing my story and learning the,
um,
learning the history and not just the Veranda,
but what really is relevant to the entire world.
Because I think we all are looking for the same thing to be happy.
We just look for it in different ways.
But if we can be informed and how to find it in the right way,
I think we're able to change.
And I sit with our,
no,
I stayed,
my friend used to be a white supremacy and I met this person who,
um,
who's in the KKK.
I was for some,
somehow I find myself myself in the sewers,
but,
but this guy,
um,
he,
his name is Chris,
he was reforming.
So he was still in the K K K and I didn't even know that care care case still
exist,
but it does.
So he was sitting across from me and trying to reform.
But I so how when when we were talking about
about love and he was really shy,
he didn't want to let it out but,
and that we'll ask him so many questions,
why do you do these and did the,
why did you do that?
But when he got to the,
where I asked him,
so are you a cure with Muslim?
He was really aggressive and really aggressive.
I got scared and then you could talk like really talk and it was like,
yes,
I am going to say how,
why,
how about children who are Muslim?
And he said,
you never know.
You never know what those kids have done.
There was say why in those dresses?
And they say,
what do you mean there's like maybe they have something,
a bomb or anything.
So he was,
then he became the person that he is.
But when he was learning how to reform,
when he was trying to be a nice person in the front,
in front of a black girl,
she was really quiet and shy and,
and he would even cry.
Um,
because they told him it was the first time,
it's a facade across a table with a black person.
And,
and I think,
uh,
if we can,
we can be able to switch to that.
He can use that,
that strength and that strength in him that comes out when he thinks about what
he hates so much to use it when it's thinking about what he loves so much.
And I think we all have that capacity.
We can,
we,
cause we grow up what we feed,
you know,
we have those two sides in ourselves and we'll feed more light in us.
We really,
it really,
it really comes up cause I used to not be this girl.
I used to be angry all the time about to everyone and everything.
You're shocked.
Leave that are used to today.
Thank you.
And I used to have and my mom,
I will spend months and not talking to my mom,
blaming her,
not giving me the life of that I want and she doesn't really have any.
But I still always still feel like I want more from her and whatever that was
not going on in my life.
I'll find somebody to blame the children of perpetrators.
I blame them that they have everything on.
I don't,
and it's because of them.
So banging of victimization mode,
it makes us like giving ourselves a justification of um,
of hating and,
and we're really,
really,
when you hate for some reason,
I don't know.
Cause you know,
even children when they don't want something there,
they come out like really strong.
Like I don't want that.
And then when they left something that miss shy away.
But I think that's what we learn so we can really be able to teach how to be
excited when something wonderful is happening.
How,
or we've done something wonderful than,
uh,
than we can.
We can change the way we see life and yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks for being here.
You're incredible.
You my
question is more about the post genocide and recovery,
specifically the role that the government plays in that.
I think if you look at the immediate years following and the way that Paul
Kagame they've really embraced international trade and turn the economy around
really quickly is undeniable,
but then you fast forward to today,
almost 20 years later,
some people would say he's an authoritarian.
Um,
I don't know if that's true or not,
but I'm curious if you think that you guys are in a place where you can now have
more of a,
somewhat of a cleaner democracy,
if you still think that it needs to be a lot tighter government control to keep
things back on,
to keep things on track.
Thank you.
That's a really tough one.
It's Google.
I did not know what I'm getting myself into.
Um,
so Rwanda very,
it's a very complicated country,
very complicated.
And as you can imagine after the genocide,
um,
the country was a mess and um,
and do behind a lot of,
uh,
people different.
I don't know.
Let me see how I'm going to describe this because we had two t's,
will fled Rwanda.
The were the ones I explained it and they 10 to 50 years,
so they grew up in neighboring countries in Burundi,
Congo,
Uganda and Tanzania.
And after the genocide read it,
they say the,
the cause of the genocide or the conflict was because the children who were born
and grew up in the neighboring countries,
they were in exile and they were never taken as a Congolese or burned down.
So they were always refuges there.
So they always wanted to come back home.
And that for the who took government,
that was in power then they told them that it's not,
it was the country that the Highbury Mana,
the president in his speech he used,
sometimes I say how the prison can have that kind of speech,
but he would say that Rwanda is like a glass full of water and if you tried to
drop to drop a little bit of one drop of water in it spreads.
So you told,
he will say the one is full already.
Nobody can come in if you try to come in and with spread and the spread is,
was it was,
it was blood.
So when the,
the Tutsis tried to come in 1990,
they killed a lot of Tutsis inside the country and they,
even publicly there was say on a radio is that if you,
if you've tried to come in,
we can kill your families so that we have space for you.
Um,
so when general site ended after the genocide ended though though the Tutsis who
were leaving in a neighboring countries came back in Rwanda and the,
the,
the in the,
and the perpetrator has fled,
were fleeing to Congo,
which still now they still have a rebel group,
the Congo that's growing and the word either Hutus who weren't going in jail and
there weren't more direct Hutus and there were survivors,
which was 30% of the two days in a row on a very small number of survivors.
So there were all these groups coming in,
this little tiny country with a different,
some of them are excited,
others has lost everything,
others are coming back home or they have a victory or they are fleeing.
So sue was calm.
It was a very,
very different dif,
difficult country.
And just having all those mixed of feelings,
um,
who,
it was hard.
It was,
but there was no really a quick solution to fix what has just happened.
The first with the first thing was to bury the dead bodies and,
and move on.
So
for me as a survivor,
there was no time to grieve.
There wasn't what it was.
There was just no time because you have to leave again and on the same,
uh,
the same speed as everyone else was coming home.
So the con then the economy was not as horrible because they come back with
things or though the houses were destroyed and all of the,
but that was for the survivors.
So when and we had to go on that system,
go back to school,
do this and this and this was always,
um,
that's why like my mom now,
the time is coming out now because she never had that time.
And now with the economy and everything,
it's way before I came,
I worked in a rural areas that are places,
there are people really,
really hungry,
really hungry.
They have one meal a day,
a terrible one.
So there's of course there is done that is happening.
The,
the,
because also mostly though the entire world,
those students still jumping the channel side by the,
after there was a lot of nonprofits that came in Rwanda.
There's suits very,
it's very vague situation.
I was a student of 27 years old and um,
I'm not even in the politics.
I don't know how it can make really like touch it and,
or detangler it.
Do you have confidence in the current government that's there still?
I've never known any other government shouldn't.
I've never known any other um,
government.
That's the um,
the old,
cause I,
yeah,
the,
the who took government.
I was a kid,
I was a child.
I just,
I really,
really didn't understand the assistant.
And this is the only government have even known.
And of course there's a lot of change and there is,
and leading a country like Rwanda,
it takes a special
kind of individual to be able to really control those kinds of minds that are
completed.
It's,
yeah,
it's really,
I can,
I
don't know,
like how a team,
yeah,
it's really complicated.
It's not perfect,
but at least we're not.
Uh,
it's not nine,
1994.
Yes.
At least we were not there.
And hopefully we'll never go back there.
Hopefully we learn
our lesson and,
um,
and when did,
will have peace somewhere in the near future.
Thank you.
I hope I just responded.
Well,
thank you.
So we're,
um,
we're,
we're basically out of time,
but one,
one final question.
Um,
oh,
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I didn't even see you over there.
How about you?
She was the last question.
Okay.
Um,
I think an easier one.
Uh,
there's so much wisdom and you've had so many experiences and it's basically an
amazing person.
Um,
thank you.
What are your,
um,
drink fear life going forward?
Like what do you want to do?
What do I want to do?
If it's a hard question,
Aye,
I want to do this,
you know,
like,
um,
I wanna I love inspiring people.
I want,
I love,
especially as children and,
uh,
I want to write more.
I wanted to touch as many lives as I can before I die.
And it's hard.
I remember Aaron and I were in Boise I think two weeks ago and it was,
um,
a human right.
Um,
uh,
[inaudible] month,
Westman,
center of human rights.
And the director came to pick me up from the airport and then he said it then,
uh,
pricing is a really wonderful,
and he was talking to me,
but he was kind of what your dad kind of preparing me for the talk and he was
having a conversation in a car ride.
And then I was asking me how I feel when I do this.
Um,
and I'll say I'm,
I'm fine,
but I didn't tell,
I never wanted culturally,
we don't really,
even if you ask me what did you have for lunch,
I wouldn't tell you.
So we always say,
where are you going?
I'm going down there or how are you?
I'm fine even if I'm dying.
And so he asked me that in the fit,
I'm fine.
And then he said,
you know,
I'm a few years ago I had,
I've had a friend who was a holocaust survivor.
Her name was,
um,
her name was rose barrel.
And I asked her how she felt after the talk and,
and then,
and then she said,
you know,
then,
um,
when I speak it,
you hear it.
And when,
when I speak it,
I see it.
And,
and that really scared me because this is cause I knew that this is what I
wanted to do and they know a lot of survivors do to do it.
But then I knew that it takes me a long time to get over a tog fixing me.
At least I have to be able to talk,
call my friends right after the tall.
Have to distract myself.
It takes me a list a few days or two weeks to really get over the talk.
And I thought the more I do it,
I will give them better.
So asked her,
how old was she?
He said she wasn't
promising.
How am I really is doing that to myself?
Maybe I should quit.
But when,
when he was saying,
and I said,
oh,
that's not fun.
I don't know if I'm going to keep it.
I'm doing this.
And he said,
but didn't remember she started when she was 81.
So she really never talked about it until she wasn't he one.
And it's always all inside her.
And um,
and they said,
oh,
maybe because I started young and maybe I 40,
I'll be fine.
So I want to keep doing it.
I know sometimes it's hard.
When I met Iran,
when I published the book,
I was creating public speaking,
then I should just go work somewhere entertainment.
And I went to CBS,
I need to tell me tonight,
and everyone was a Canadian.
When you're ready,
just let me know.
And because you have to be out there and inspiring people.
And that when by that time I was,
I was,
I couldn't,
I will be.
So being on the stage,
of course I did cry a little bit today,
but I used to really,
really cry like,
so I was like,
this is not pretty,
I should just not do this.
So the more I do it,
the more I,
I remember most of them because the more I think about it comes back and I,
but I think,
um,
I took meditation classes now and my deep meditation teacher told me,
what happens to you,
Hopkins for you?
So it really made me trim meets with so that I can help someone else.
So I want to do this the rest of my life.
And,
uh,
hopefully,
40 or 30 something,
I won't be still seeing it
behalf of Google and the group here.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
There's a book signing odd that will be happening in the back.
If any of you would like to get the Dean's new book.
Thank you.